80番 80
番 ウデカンヒ ナヤンティ ネッティカ ウスカーラ ナメヤンティ テージャナーン ダールン ナメヤンティ タッ
チャカ アッターナン ダメヤンティ パンディタって腕なんですね
ウデカンヒ ナヤンティ ネッティカ
ネッティカっていうのは水をあちこち水路を作って仕事をすることなんですね
それも一つの技術 現代でもね
イリゲーションというのは特別な工学エンジニアリングの側面ですからね
昔は別にでっかいダム作ったりとかはね
そんなに大胆なイリゲーションはなかったんですけど
まあ一応田んぼには水が必要ですからね
それで川が下の方に流れてるしね
それがちゃんと田んぼに行ってもらわないと
まあそれぐらいの水路っていうのは
まあ昔からね 人間が田んぼを作り始めてからやっていたことで
まあどんな大学に入らなくても
その技術はあったみたいですね
それはネッティカという普通の大工さんたちがちゃんと水を好きなところに持っていく
ウスカーラ ナメヤンティ テージャナーン
ウスカーラっていうのは
この矢を作る人々は 木の枝ですからね
矢に使うのは 木の枝はもう何にも
矢には決してふさわしくはないんです
重さが違うし 曲がっているし
それはしっかりした矢に
矢になるように この矢作りの人々はそれを作るんです
ダールン ナメヤンティ タッチャカ
タッチャカっていうのは
まあ大工さんですね ダールン
木材をもう好きなように使うんだと
家具を作ったり いろんなもう形にしたりして家具を作るんですね
そのようにアッターナン ダメヤンティ パンディタ
理性のある人は自己を戒めるんだよと
コントロールするんだと
まあとにかくパーリ語の単語を見てください
まずナヤンティという単語が
動詞が出てきて ナヤンティというのは
このまあリーディングするとか導くというね
水を好きなように導くんですね
あっち行きなさい こっち行きなさいと
それは上手な人が言う通りに
水がちゃんとそう言っているところに行ってくれるんです
本来は水はそうじゃないんです
随分わがままなんです
本来は水っていうのはものすごくわがままで恐ろしくて
自分がどこら辺に流れるのかということは決まっているんです
しかし それが自分の役に立つように流れてもらうんですね
導いてもらうんですね
ナヤンティという動詞
ナメヤンティという動詞
次に 2行目に書いてあるね
それは曲げるという意味なんですね
それから調整するという意味もありますね
それで昔の矢はね 一応木で作りましたからね
矢は作るため 矢を作るためには結構技術は必要なんですよ
もう もうすごい重さによってもね
飛んだり飛ばなかったりするし
これはちゃんと狙ったところに当たってもらわないとね
だからこの そこはね 木の枝をね
しっかりと 曲がってはならないんですよ
矢は しっかりまっすぐでないと
木はまっすぐにするっていうことは大変な仕事なんです
自然にはまっすぐにならないんです
そこはもう調整するんですね
あらゆる工夫をして ちゃんと木を曲げて調整して
自分のものに 好きなように矢を作る
3番目の動詞もナマヤンティなんですね
それも曲げる 調整するっていう意味で
その場合は木材ですね
タッチャカっていうのは大工さんですね
大工さんが木の丸太を持ってきて
これでタンス作るわ 椅子を作るわとかね
もう考えられないんですね
普通 今あまり見すぎちゃってどうってことないと思いますけど
そうじゃないんですよ
できない人には想像もできない
だから木を切って曲げて調整して
あらゆる家具やら家やら作るんですね
大工さんは だからその場合もナマヤンティという言葉を使っているんですね
4行目の動詞はダマヤンティという
その場合は戒めるという
調教するということなんですね
わがままでいい加減で
もうどうしてももう言うことを聞いてくれないものを調教するんですね
躾するんですね だから調教する
躾する 戒めるという意味でダマヤンティというんですね
これはかなりよく使う単語なんですね
それで我々の心も こういう言うことを聞いてくれないんですね
随分勝手なんですね まあ水と同じなんですね
自分流れたい方へ流れたいだけ
結果は気にもしない だから川の水もね
溢れたら自分好きなところから出ていくんであって
ここら辺人家あるんだからね
別なところで洪水になった方がいいんじゃないか
そんなのは全く関係ないんです
もう言うこと聞いてくれない
もう木の枝持ってきてまっすぐになりなさいと言ったってまっすぐになるわけじゃないんです
同じく心も我々の言うことは聞いてくれるわけじゃないんですね
それで理性のある人は
それは調教するんです
言い訳はしないんですね
世の中を見ると結構言い訳するんですね
人間はそうなんですからとかね
人間はそうなんですよ
ああなんですっていうのは
これとんでもない 理性のない無知な人の話なんですよ
だから人間は自分の心がだらしなくて
悪で 感情の奴隷でね 理性がなくて
怒りやら欲やら無知が言うことなら聞く
怒りが何か言ったらすぐやってあげるんですね
欲が何か言ったらそれをすぐやると
しかし 理性が言うことは聞かないんですね
やりたくないとすぐ思っちゃうんです
それは人間の本来の姿だからどうしようもないでしょうっていうのはね
もうそれこそ無知な人の話なんですよ
だから人間っていうのは
人間を褒め称えてくれるところにはすぐ群がっちゃうんですね
だからこの詐欺師たちはいつでもたくさん人を集めて
たくさんの人のたくさん金を取りたければ
とにかく褒めるんですね
認めるんですね 人間を
人間を認めるんじゃない
人間のだらしないところを認めるんです
そうすると だらしない人間にとっては随分気分がいいんです
だからそれは無知な世界で恐ろしい世界でやることです
慈しみの世界でやることじゃないんですね
慈しみがある世界なら
相手のことは心配するんですよ
言う通りにやってあげないんです
心を調教することを戒めることを言うんですね
だから例えばある人はね
私が口がうるさくて いつでも失言ばっかりで
そういう性格ですよと
ああまあそれはしょうがないんだからね
じゃあみんなみんな我々気をつけましょうと
あまり気にしないことにしますからと
気にするなよと言うと気分がいいんです
逆にそれってだらしないでしょうと
もうちょっと自分をコントロールしたらどうでしょうかと
何か喋る前にちょっと観察して
こんなこと言っていいのか悪いのかと考えたらいかがでしょうかというと
すごく腹が立たんですね
なんで悪い人ですかと
だから普通人間っていうのはそういうことで
自分の悪さを正当化してくれるところが好きなんですね
成長したくないんですよ
だからこの場合は この自然のものを見なさいよと
心が心がないものさえも
理性 智慧がある人はね
能力ある人が見事に管理して幸福になっているのではないかと
勝手に流れる水をね ちゃんと水路を作って流しちゃえば
もう田んぼができるできますからね
これどれぐらい幸福になるんですかね
そうでないと何も食べ物なくなるでしょうに
だからそれぐらいの能力で人類助かってますよ
だからなぜ戒めること悪いのかっていうことなんです
随分戒めることが何か悪いと
みんな嫌われるんだと
やっぱりまずいと思ってるんですね
みんな嫌われるんだから
やっぱりそこは言うのはよしましょうと
これって人類にとっていいことかと
仏教の世界の例で言えば
この戒めることを修行することは嫌だと
そこで一般人も嫌でしょうし
だから一般の人に仏教を語っても嫌がりますよと
じゃあやめましょうと
それで聖職者たちも自分でも修行したくないんですね
なんかないのかといって
本来悟ってるんだと みんな生命は
生命はもともと悟り開いている如来そのものであると
気分がいいんですね そういう
別に修行しなくたっていいんじゃないかと
それがブッダの教えだと言ったら
大勢の人が集まるんです
私はそのままでいいや
そのままでいいやと で
自分好き勝手な感情やら無知やら
もう仏教として語ったりする
そして人間の狙いは商売だからね
それに使ったりもするっていうことは
歴史的にあったことなんですね
だから戒めるの嫌っていうことは
もう人間 仏教の中ででもあるんですね
他のことは言うまでもないんです
他の世界は しかし お釈迦様が違うんですね
戒める 戒めるべきですと
こんなのは当たり前ではないかと
頭冷やして考える必要
冷やす必要もないんです
ただもう当たり前のことなんです
あまり難しいことなら頭冷やして考える必要ありますけど
こんなに難しいことでもないんです
世の中を見ると 全て調教することで
管理することで成り立っているでしょうに
自然のままで何一つも役には立ちませんよ
だから 我々着ている服にしたっても
それはもう管理しているものでしょうに
自然のままのものじゃないでしょうに
自然なままのものと言えば
このアダムみたいに葉っぱ枚しかなく
なくなりますけど だから
いろんな過程を経て 人間が着られる服を作っているんですね
それでもう技術の上 技術をかけて
いろんな素材作ったりして
厚いものやら薄いものやら
柔らかいものやら硬いものやら
光るものやら もういろんなものを作っているんですね
それでもう洗っても元の形に戻るものまで形状なんとかというね
もう形状記録する服まで作っているんですよ
そうするとアイロンかけなくても大丈夫なんです
だから そういうことの恵みを受けながら
戒めは良くないと 気持ち悪いと
嫌やと どこまであべこべか
へ理屈かということなんです
戒めることで成り立っているんです
で かなり値段ついている宝石ありますね
あれ 掘ってみるとただの石なんですよ
見たことありますかね？原石は
誰でももう素人は何だこれと思うものなんです
先生 それよりガラスの破片だったら
これもっともっと綺麗でしょうと思うかもしれません
すぐかっこ悪いんです
原石はただの石なんです
でもそれがもうそれから名前なんてね
負けるというかね 調教するんです
調教ではないんですけど
いろいろ だからこの石をね
あれ 味覚専門家が石を見て
この模様はどんな形になっているのかとかね
見てちょうどうまい具合に
それはもうカッティングというんですけどね
ジムカッティングポリッシングとかね
それをもうカッティングして磨いて
かなり高価な宝石にするんです
そういうことで この戒めなく何も成り立ちません
良いものはね だから理性があってほしいとお釈迦様が言うのはそういうことなんです
理性があればもう戒めは嫌やとはあんまりにもバカバカらしいことは言わないんです
地球は平らだよという方がもっとマシなんです
見る限り平らで見えますから
戒めは嫌やという気持ちがもっと無知なんですね
そういうことで この教では
心には戒めが必要であるということは言っているんですね
それがわかると すごく気持ちよく自分を育てることはできます
自分をちゃんと戒めておかなくちゃ
自分をしっかり育ててこなくちゃとかね
いうことがすごく明るく大事なことであるようにね
もう大根であろうか もうもうホウレンソウであるか
そのまま食べるんじゃなくて
料理して食べるでしょうに
ジャガイモ買ってきた人
あ じゃあこのまま食べましょうと思わないんです
何か料理しようと思うでしょうに
それぐらいの気分で考えなくてはいけないんです
このケーキ買ってきた気分ではダメなんです
買ってきたケーキでも
そのまま食べるとえらい気持ち悪いでしょ
ケーキを持ってきてそのまま食べると
それは一応包丁でね 切って分けて
皿にのせて まあティッシュやらね
またフォークやらね 揃って食べるとかっこいいんですよ
気分もいいんです それでいくらかの管理は
ただケーキにしたっても必要なんです
まあケーキは買う時ももうちゃんとそういう調教はもう終わってますけど
もうそのまま食べられる状態にして売ってますけど
しかし それでもいくらか手を加えた方が
より一層かっこよくなるんです
だから我々はこの心育てるっていうことは
その程度の当たり前の気分にならなくちゃいけないんです
そんな大胆なことでもなんでもないんだと
人が何かもう愚かな人はいろんな嫌味言うでしょうに
例えば酒やめようと思った人
あんた何やってるの？人間ってのは酒好きでしょうとかね
あれこれと言うでしょうに
だから一発でね あんた米買ってきてそのまま食うんでしょうかと聞いてみれば
店で米を買ってきたら
はい そのまま袋開けて
じゃあ食べましょうと
それってもう原始的で
もうもうもう牛豚じゃないんだからね
だから人間も生まれてそのままではいいわけじゃないんだよと
いろいろもう調教しなくちゃいけないんだと
躾しなくちゃいけないんだと
これが私の躾だよと あんた何か文句あるのかという態度を取らなくちゃいかんですよ
私の親でもないのにいちいち言うなよと
なのにもう誰かさんが友達とか友達でもないんですけどね
自分が酒飲まない 飲まないことにしたいんだけど
やっぱりもう友達のあれで
もうやっぱりやめられませんよとかねと
よく私に聞くでしょうね
本当話にならないことなんです
何言うのかと 親でもないのに
自分のこと心配もしていないのに
人は心を育てることをやってはいけないと堂々と言うんだからね
その場合は あなたはあなた好きなように生きてくださいと
あなたはそのままでいいという主義でしょうと
だからもうスーパーでチキンやら豚肉買ったらそのまま食べてくださいと
何かもう処理する必要はないんだよと
米買ってきたらそのまま食べてくださいと
私は人間は成長するべきだと思ってるんだよと
毎日毎日成長するべきだと思ってるんだよというところは
理性的な話で ベースに厳しい論理でも何でもないんです
だから 随分シンプルに物事を考えればね
結構頭が動くんですよ
だから心の戒めの場合はね
道徳を守ることやらね
瞑想することやらね そういうことで大胆なことじゃないんです
もう 米買ったら炊飯器でそこはご飯にするでしょうに
そんなのは変ですかね
変だ おかしいんだとかね
は言わないでしょうに
だから自然のままにいることが変なんですよ
部屋はそのままで一回も掃除機かけませんと
ゴミは溜まるだけで捨てませんと
ゴミを分別するどころかそのまんまだと
それが原始的で変でしょ
ゴミをそのまま捨てるんじゃなくて
ちゃんと分別してその日で出すっていうことが普通でしょうに
大胆なことじゃないでしょうに
なぜ道徳になってくるとそんなことを言うんですかね
なぜ心が心の問題になってくると
そういうことを言うんですかね
心でしょう 一番大事な宝物は心が命でしょうに
心がなかったらただのものですからね
心がなければ生命もいないでしょうに
生命だ 生き物だっていうことは心ですからね
そこも本来のままではダメなんです
仏教は心も物質も二種類で入れてるだけで
物のように考えているんですよ
結局は 物質はそのままではダメでしょうし
管理しなくちゃ 心もそのままではダメなんです
あらゆる管理しなくちゃいけないんです
[音楽]はい まあまあ
そういうことで ごく当たり前のことのごとく
自分の心を戒めなさいと
それは理性があることであると
理性があるということは
ずいぶん大胆で どうもどうもおっかないということじゃなくて
ごく当たり前のことなんです
はい まあこのエピソードのこの芸に透けているエピソードがありまして
それだけは一応私はだいたいは紹介しますけど
まあ他っていうのはあんまり
ちょっと途中で嫌になるんですね
ストーリーを読むと これもかなりかなりかなり長くて長くて
まあだからこうストーリーは宿題にしないとね
これお釈迦様のね  第1番目の弟子
サーリプッタ尊者ですね
智慧の第1というね で
サーリプッタ尊者のあの信者さんの一人の子供の話なんです
これにまた過去物語あると
これとあるわあるわあるわ
まあもしあのテキスト持ってる方々いるならば
この省略バージョンじゃなくて
これものすごい長いストーリーがありまして
いくつか繋げてあって
読んだ方がもしかすると面白いか面白くないか分かりませんだけど
だからあの大事なところだけ言うならば
サーリプッタ尊者と仲良くするあの知り合いの家族がいて
その家族にまあ男の子が生まれて
その子がもうほとんどもう怪しいんだよ
どんな子供  7歳にしますからね
この仏典は どうか分かりませんだけど
子供の話が来ると必ず年は7歳ですね
その子はもう7歳になったところで
まあ母親に出家したいと言うんですね
母親はなかなかこの子供の性格も知っていて
で 普通とは違う頭のいい子だと
だからまあ出家したいというならば
それをちゃんとさせてあげなくちゃいけないと
小さい時は本人が自分の将来の道を決めたんだからね
これすごいことなんですね
それでまあどうせあげるならばサーリプッタ尊者にあの弟子にしますということで
サーリプッタ尊者の弟子にするんです
この智慧の第一人者ですけど
現代知識人と違ってサーリプッタ尊者が性格はちょっと違うんです
ものすごい優しいんです
もう自我張らないんですね
自分がサーリプッタだよとお釈迦様の第1番
そこも思ってないんです
智慧の第1人者としてお釈迦様が認定しているんだよと
と思ったこともないんです
とても謙虚で ごく普通にいるんですね
そういうことだから この子供扱いはもうかなり智慧が必要なんですよ
簡単じゃないんです 親たちは自分が産んだ子供だから何とか何とかやっていますけど
誰にもしっかり育てることはそうできるわけじゃないんです
かなりそれがすごく すごく知恵が働く親ならもう育てられます
なぜかというと 子供っていうのはすごくわがままで
もう善悪もわからないし
自分はやりたいことをやりたいだけなんですよ
しかし ダメという一言が嫌なんです
子供は ダメとかやめなさいとか
何やってるのかとか なんでこんなことやるのかとかね
そういう言葉っていうのは子供は大嫌いなんです
そういう言葉を使うと
もう正しいしつけにならないんです
では どうやって子供を育てますかね
ダメと言わないで やめなさいとも言わないで
なんでこんなことやるのかとも言わないで
どうやって育てますかね
だからそこがもう知恵が必要なところなんですね
ある子供がいて これ実の話で
もう母親がもう無理も心配で
何でも危ない危ない危ないばっかり言っているんです
どれほど言っているのかと
その子は自分のことを自分でも危ない危ないと言っているんです
そこでまあ私と仲良くなって
私はあまり何も言わないんですね
だから子供から見ればもう危ないと言うべきところなんです
危ないと言わないんだから
本人自分で言うんです
だからといって本人が言うだけで気をつけるかというと
いくらでも当然子供だからね
そんな危ないところから身を守ることはできるわけでもないんです
私がそれで結構危ないところに連れて
わざと連れて行くんです
危ないと思うことをわざとやらせるんです
あの呪文何回唱えればいいかということでもありましてね
それはそういうことじゃなくて
こういう風に言うんですね
ああ これは気をつけるところですね
これはもう自分で気をつけろところだよとかね
それで否定は何もないんです
何かやらないといったら危ないんですよ
それを自分で気をつけてやることでしょうと
危ないということは取り消しているんです
だから気をつければ別に危なくはないということなんです
道路を渡る時 待ってなさい
危ないんだから信号変わるまでと私は言わない
渡れるところになったら自分で気をつけて
自分で気をつけることやと
言って本人がじっと信号見ていて
青くなった途端 先に青信号だと言って
もう さっさと渡るんです
だからその場合は 子供にとっては面白いことをやっているんです 「
待ちなさい まだ赤信号だから」と言うと
これはダメなんですよ
お前ダメなものよと言ったことと同じなんです
逆にまあ誰か責任を取ってくるでしょう
親がいるんだから ということで無責任になるんですね
で 親から離れなくなっちゃうんですね
だからこの言い方って微妙に知恵を使って言わなくちゃいけないんです
だから子育てっていうのはそう簡単なことじゃないんです
これが他人の子供になると
ものすごい大変な仕事なんです
しかし 知恵さえあれば
何のことなく面白くできます
だから 子供の精神状況も壊すことなく
できることできますよ
そういうわけで この出家する子供たちはどちらかというとほとんどみんなサーリプッタ尊者のところにあの入れていたみたいんですね
だから逆に言えば サーリプッタ尊者のような偉大なる知恵の方が
かなり頭が勉強している
ものすごい鋭い賢人たちとね
人々と説法したり 話し合ったり
ディスカッションしたりするというならば
それが本来の仕事なんですけど
かなり手強い もうものすごい極限に邪見に陥っている人とかね
そこから立ち上げるということは
もう上がるということは大変だから
それはサーリプッタ尊者みたいなもう究極の知恵のある人と話し合った方がいいんです
なのにサーリプッタ尊者がもうほとんど子供の見てみることに
なっていたんです しかし
知恵の第一人者だから
それは全然負担でも何でもなかったんです
サーリプッタ尊者のところで
何か出家した子供たちは随分楽に
微塵も嫌な気持ちがなく
随分楽しく楽にいたみたいですね
だからお釈迦様さえも心配したのは
自分の息子様もね サーリプッタのところにいたんだから
この人と遊んだりして
偉大なるサーリプッタだとね
何か遊び相手にしてもらったら困るということなんです
遊び相手にするべき人じゃないんです
でも 子供にしてみれば何のこともないんです
怖いことも何ともないんです
だからお釈迦様がこそこそサーリプッタ尊者にラーフラ尊者に聞いたのは 「
あんた偉大なる人を尊敬する？」と聞いたんですね
で ラーフラ尊者がすぐ分かって
これは自分の先生のことですと
それはもうちゃんと尊敬していますよと
ということで お釈迦様も安心で
それならよかったと 遊んでもらったりばっかりだったら
もうやっぱり父親として困りますからね
で このシャミーもそれもうサーリプッタ尊者のところで出家して
別にサーリプッタ尊者がね
あれしなさい これしなさい
修行しなさい あれこれそれもないんです
ちゃんとこの適当に扱っていて
だからあまり何も激しく言わないことは
サーリプッタ尊者にはお釈迦様は困っていて
何回も言ったんですよ
あんたしっかりしなさいよと
だから 自分たちの弟子たちの中で
全くふざけて悪いことを言う子
わがままなことをする人がいたっても
サーリプッタ尊者は怒鳴ったりはしません
だからそれが困りますからね
厳しく言うべきところは言ってほしいという気持ちはお釈迦様にあったんですけど
サーリプッタじゃないんですね
言われているのに 言われているのに
もうやらないんです だから何か不思議な方なんですよ
知らないわけでもないし
怖いというわけでもないんだけど
何か本人が気づいて悪いことをやめるまで待っているんですね
だからサーリプッタ尊者のところで一人前になって出て行ったお坊さんたち
何人かグループがいて
これはだらしなくてわがままで
一応大きくたら 何人何年かいたらもう一人で生活しなくちゃあかんだからね
でもサーリプッタ尊者のところで仏教を学んだり修行していると
それはしてないんですね
これが一般の自分たちがお寺一つもらって
それで信者さんと一緒に遊ぶわ
もうやりたい放題なことをやるわ
信者さんもバカたちで
ああ とってもとてもいいお坊さんたちだとすぐ愛させてくれるわと
よく家のことやら何でも個人的なことでもな
よく聞いてくれるわとかね
お坊さんたちと違って
一緒にもう家にまで中にまで入って
一緒にご飯食べたりもするわと
ものすごい親しいということで
もうこの二人のやりたい放題で
二人だけじゃなくてグループがいたんですね
これで戒律までもういろいろ犯したり
もう仏教のしきたりもかなり壊したりっていってね
かなり力強いんですね
この問題が出ていたら
出てきたら あれ管理できないんだと
あんまりにもわがままになっていて
お釈迦様はなんとか解決しなくちゃいけない
お釈迦様はひと言葉サーリプッタ尊者に「あれってあなたの弟子でしょう」と
サーリプッタ尊者何も言わなかったんですね
それでお釈迦様が退去命令というかね
お寺から出て行きなさいと
で 退去命令決めて退去命令したっても
これ実行は大変です 信者さんと仲間作ってね
それに反対したら 他の群たちはもう反対運動何もしないでしょうね
阿羅漢たちは お釈迦様がしたことは退去命令で
それをサーリプッタ尊者に言ったんです
あなた自分たちの弟子たちだから
それを実行してくださいと
お釈迦様に何も言いませんだから
サーリプッタ尊者の性格とは違うことですよ
わざとやらせるのは あまりにも優しいんだから
しょうがない お釈迦様の命令だから 「
はい わかりました」と言って
弟子たちをお寺から追い出したんですね
まあそれはサーリプッタ尊者できることはできるんだからね
サーリプッタ尊者が来たんだということで
一般の人々の中でね かなり有名でしたし
で 人々がみんな集めてきてね
お布施してサーリプッタ尊者の話を聞いて
よく仏教 サーリプッタ尊者そんな話
あの連中にも一つ一言言いに来たんだ
それないんです だからうまくいったんです
信者さんに説法して まあだから偉大なる方のすごい謙虚な姿とかを見たりすると
信者さんも心が変わって
これこそ仏教で こんな方でもこんな感じでしょうとかね
でもついでに実はね 私はこう
いうことをできたんだよと
それはそれをやらなくちゃというので
それなら何のことなく物事も決まったんです
追い出すことができたんです
ですから このいくつかエピソードあります
サーリプッタのこの優しさというかね
あまりものをいわゆる厳しく言わないというところはね
で トラブったことがありますって
ありました はい この沙弥はそういうことではなくて
逆なんですね ある日 托鉢に出て 2
人で 托鉢に出たら この田んぼを通っていったと
行ったら この水路を作る人々も一生懸命もう大騒ぎして
もう仕事しているんですね
子供はあまりわからないんだから
サーリプッタ尊者に もう先生
あれ何やってるんでしょうかと
言うと 何のことなく それはねと
よく賢者だからね 水っていうのはこういうもので
こうやってみんな一生懸命水を自分好きなように流れる
それ大変な仕事だよと
だから無駄に川に流れる水がこうやって田んぼを通っていって
水を地面を潤って豊作にしてくれるんだよと
そういう大変な仕事をこのおじいさんたちがやってますよと
子供もということで また連れていくんですね
また托鉢にみんな出かけなくちゃいかんだからね
で サーリプッタ尊者のところはもう子供たちばっかりで
大きな長老たちがほとんどいない
子供の沙弥連れて托鉢に出て行く
子供たちは子供たちだから
あれこれしゃべるわ もうもう質問するわ
まあ全然そんなこと関係なく答えて返事して連れて行くんです
次はまたこの弓を作る村
村ですからね そういうところに行くことになって
みんな汗垂らして仕事をしています
かなり工程ありますからね
弓を作る場合に あれ何やってるのかといったら
もう全部教えてあげたんですよ
弓を作る過程から もうこれでこれで
これで こういうこうこうなって
最後にこんな風な立派な矢になりますよと
おじいさんたちが一生懸命頑張ってるんだと
おそらくまあそういう時はまあそこそこって我々もそういうふうに頑張らなくちゃいけないんだぞとかね
何となく言うでしょうね
それから大工さんの村に托鉢行った日がありまして
そこでまた大工さんの仕事をおりやらね
どのようにこの心のない者はみんな成長
育てるのか 何と言いますか
調整しているのかと教えてくれと
で 子供はいきなりわかったんですね
やっぱり自分たちも頑張らなくちゃと
自分たちが心育てるために出家したんだから
いきなりサーリプッタに言われたら
先生 だって私たちも心育てるために出家したでしょうと
そうなんですけど だったら私は瞑想しますよと
言って何のことなくそのまま帰っちゃったんです
だったらもう待っていられません
瞑想しますと サーリプッタもちょっと待ちなさいとかね
今托鉢の時間だよとかね
あんた何やってるの？それはないんです
だから子供にとってはすごく楽でしたと思いますよ
あの子は行っちゃっただけで終わっちゃったよ
話は お寺に帰ったと しかし
サーリプッタが他の子供たちと托鉢して
自分が2人分取る 受けてるんです
子供の分も だから早く早く托鉢して
自分の一食分と子供の分もいただいて
子供の分も持って早く早くお寺に行くんです
子供にご飯食べさせなくちゃと
だからそういうところですよ
すごいところはね まあなんとことかとね
なんであんたわがままでとかね
今托鉢の時間だとか そういう余計なしつけがなかったんですね
その代わり 何のことなく自分が父親みたいにご飯を持っていくと
しかし この子 すごい智慧のある子供で
もういきなり瞑想がどんどん見るうちに成長していく
で お釈迦様が だいたいこのお釈迦様が気になるんで
誰でも修行に入ったら
お釈迦様はそこはチェックするんですね
お釈迦様は感じたんですね
あの子供はもう修行に入ったんだと
そしたらどういう調子かなと見たら
結構うまく真面目に頑張っているんです
すごい真面目に頑張っていて
あ これならもう何のことなく悟りに達するぞとお釈迦様はそれ知っていて
しかしサーリプッタ尊者はもうそういうことに構わず
子供に午前中ご飯食べさせないと夜は食べられないんだからね
これは子供に悪いんだよと
それしか考えてないんです
ご飯を持って鉢を持って子供がいるところに行くんですね
これお釈迦様はこれがまずいと
瞑想がすごい調子に乗っているんだから
この人がいて喋っちゃうとね
もう子供が瞑想をやめるしまずいと思ってもうお釈迦様そこら辺散歩しているんです
サーリプッタ尊者ご飯持って行ったら
お釈迦様がいたんだから礼をしなくちゃいけないし
で お釈迦様が何のことなく普通話をするんです
どうでしょうかとかね
あれこれとか 日常の話とかね
お釈迦様 私はちょっと
ちょっと待ってくださいと言えないんだからね
今そんな話時間がないんだと
じゃあ子供にご飯をあげてから
お釈迦様と話をしたいんだと
それはできません だからずっとお釈迦様と話をしていたんです
お釈迦様も結構質問したりしますからね
これはどういうふうに言います
思いますかとかね お釈迦様にたっても結構話したい
話し相手 話したい相手なんです
サーリプッタ尊者が だからお釈迦様はすごい智慧の第一
世界一というか 生命一でしょうね
我々人間の中で智慧の第一人者だから
やっぱりいろいろ仲良く積まる話はあるんですね
サーリプッタ尊者にしたっても
もう頭の悪い人々と喋るよりはお釈迦様と喋ると気分がよいし
だからそこで話はどんどんどんどん進むんです
お釈迦様その間 子供の心の成長ぶりはどうでしょうかと
自分の超能力でチェックしているんですね
その子は悟りに達したんです
その一回で 悟りに達したなと分かったら
お釈迦様が「あんたなんでご飯
なんでこの鉢でご飯持っているんでしょうか」と
そしたらお釈迦様に「子供がいてね
もう托鉢もう逃げちゃったんだと
修行するんだと思って
だから私は子供のご飯持っていこうかなと
もう午前中になる前に」とかね
もうかなり時間経ってますよ
もう お釈迦様「そうですか
はいはい どうぞどうぞ」と
お釈迦様は自分のところに戻ったんです 「
はい ご飯あげてください」と
だからサーリプッタ尊者が戒律の形式しきたり考えて
これはまずいと思っただけで
お釈迦様はそういうことよりは悟ることが大事だと言ってわざとだから何時間経ったか分からないんです
で 後でご飯食べさせたんです
そういうエピソードなんですね
だからそこはまとめて偈にしているんです
後でね 大変な珍しい出来事だから話題になって
それでお釈迦様はその偈を唱えたんですね
で それだけです 何かその
お釈迦様のこの言葉について
何かもっと知りたいことがありますかね
とってもシンプルな分かりやすい教えですけど
分かりやすい教えですけど
即席に知ってるわけじゃない
みんな戒め嫌がるんですよ
戒め嫌がるんです 誰でも
だから仏教から見れば
みんな理性のない もう変たばりな人間なんです
だから修行することやら瞑想することやら
戒律を守ることやら 決して大胆なものではないんです
そんなのは変人やってるんだぞという話じゃないんです
やらなくてはいけないこと
当たり前のことということなんです
そこだけ理解してほしいんです
道徳を守ること 自分を戒めることは
米ならそのまま食べないんだよということと同じ当たり前だと
魚買ってきてそのままパクッと食べることしないでしょうに
イワシとかサンマとか買ってきて
ビニール袋を開けてそのまま食べると
それは猫がやるんであって
人間はそこはまたいろいろ
何と言いますか 整理するんですよ
それから人間に適したものになるんです
心も同じだと 稽古事やら学ぶものやらって何ですかね
それも心の訓練でしょう
学校に行って学ぶことが当たり前だと思っているならば
やっぱり自分の性格を直すことも当たり前のことなんです
それを理解していただければ
この経典のポイントはそれなんです
そうなってくると すごい気持ちよく
楽で良い人間になれます
これって大変だということはないんです
バナナ食べる時は何のことなく皮を剥くでしょうに
どうしようかと困るんですかね
それで これ大変だと ないでしょうに
手で取って皮を剥いて食べる
そんなような感じで とっても自然で当たり前のことごとく
自分の怒りやら欲やら無知やら嫉妬やら憎しみやら
そういう感情を調教していかなくちゃいけないんです
それ楽しくなるんです
そこが大事なポイントなんです
NHK でね 南伝仏教について何か一言葉でも言わなくちゃいけないいろいろ番組があると
必ず言うセットフレーズがありますね
戒律は厳格な南方仏教か
上座部仏教とかね そう思う折り紙付きの愚か者たちだなということなんですよ
だからそれはそういうふうに日本で思っているんだからね
同じものを繰り返し言うだけでね
みんなだいたいオウム返しばかりですね
学問やら何でもかんでもね
理性もないしね もうどうしようもないんですけど
だからオウム返しでみんな言ってるんだからって
変なことに乗ってはいけません
ごく自然に ごく当たり前で物事を見ると
ものすごい知恵なんです
我々は自分で考えないで
昔誰か愚か者が言ったことだったら
そのままこれを飲み込んで
それに乗って そればっかりまた吐くんですね
だからただの吐いてるだけですよ
ゲロを出してるだけなんです
世の中は それに驚いて
また乗って 自分たちも同じものを食べて
またゲロを出す それは仏教はあまり認めません
仏教でいうこのものすごい厳しく
論理的で客観的に物事を見ること難しいかというと
そうじゃないんです ただ神がいるかいないかということにも
誰も知ったことないでしょうに
だったら知ったことも知る方法もなかったら
何でいるかと困るんですかと
どう見たっておかしいでしょうと
いるという証拠は絶対無理ということでしょ
神が存在するということは証明すること絶対無理であると
だったらどうやって神がいると信じる必要あるんですかね
だったらどうやって言うんですかね
神がいるんだそうとか
そこで矛盾でしょ キリスト教の方々に聞いたら
もう神は何でしたっけ？無限の知恵があるんだから
知恵と言わなかったよ
無限の方だから無限の能力のね
人間でこんなちっぽけな人間にはね
それはもういるかどうかもわからないんだよ
だからそれだけで矛盾でいないという話でしょうに
だったらどんな人間にも神がいるということを言えないはずなんです
もし言ったならば そうと頭がイカれてるんです
だから本を見てください
最初に神の話を持ってきた人は
当然精神的にイカれてるんです
読んでみたら だからそんなに大げさな話じゃないんです
だから無知な人々にとってはもうもう何百年もかけて本を書くは哲学は作るはもう大変です
神がいるということを言うために
ものすごい苦労してるでしょうに
それで言えば言うほどいないということの証拠になるし
そこで無神論者たちもすごく苦労するんですね
その理屈を そんな苦労しなくてもいいのに
だからこの普通に物事を当たり前で見れば
偉大なる哲学者よりは頭がすっごく良くなるんです
だからごく普通に物事を見ましょうということは
誰にでもできますよ 天才になる必要ないんです
そういうところです だから今日はポイントは
心を育てるべきかっていうところで
まあだから答え簡単です
イワシはそのままで食うのかと
米はそのままで食うのかと
それはやっぱりいろいろ調整して食べるでしょうに
調整したところで人間に品格よく文化人らしくかっこよく食べられます
心も同じことです そのままではとんでもないんだよ
ものすごく気持ち悪くて
汚くて危険で役に立ちません
はい そのポイントをよく覚えておいてください
他何かご質問がありますか？